Reed Richards descendant inspired by Dr
Doom here's the truth about Ant-Man 3's
Kang the Conqueror
although Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania will be the official debut of the
Menace known as Kang the Conqueror it's
not Jonathan Major's first rodeo in the
MCU the actor played the role of he who
remains in the first season finale of
Loki revealed to be the Mastermind
behind the timekeepers and the time
variance Authority however the
characters ties to Kang the Conqueror
were worn on his sleeve
you're a flea on the back of a dragon
then for one hell of a ride
after Loki and Sylvie confront he who
remains at the Citadel at the End of
Time Majors character Reveals His
backstory which just so happens to be
the same as Kang's from the comics he
who remains was originally a scientist
from the 31st Century who after
discovering the existence of the
Multiverse used it to make contact with
his variants across space and time
sooner or later some of those variants
waged war in pursuit of Conquering the
Multiverse and once he who remains came
out on top he isolated the sacred
timeline and created the TVA to prune
any unwanted branches Major's
performance in the Loki finale was well
received especially by MCU fans who had
correctly theorized Kang's involvement
in the earlier episodes however the
character's presence was a clear warning
sign of what's to come with the series
head writer Michael Waldron saying in an
interview with marvel.com I was trying
to really hint at that terrifying Evil
Within without going all the way there
he who remains while being an
interpretation of Kang the Conqueror
himself also has his own ties to
Marvel's comic book Origins however his
main inspiration is not the character of
the same name who created both the
timekeepers and the TV and the comics
and first debuted in the 1970s no the
MCU iteration of he who remains actually
has much more in common with a specific
variant of Kang a mortise in the comics
amortis was a version of Kang who grew
tired of conquering and retreated to a
dimension outside of space and time
known as limbo which Bears a lot of
similarity to the void in Loki there
amortis got in contact with the
timekeepers who offered him the job of
influencing events in the sacred
timeline to prevent mankind from
straying off their planned Destinies the
MCU version of he who remains is a
composite of both the original he who
remains from the comics and immortus
this is reflected in the character's
clothing in the Loki finale which
combines The Familiar purple and green
colors of immortus with the comfort of
he who remains robes in the making of
Loki on Disney plus Majors reveals he
who remains his outfit also Drew
inspiration from Genghis Khan and the
Victorian era although he's mainly known
for his antagonistic role as Kang the
Conqueror the character's long and
storied past ties him to one of Marvel's
most popular teams before he traveled
the Multiverse conquering him ruling
Kang was an Earthly scientist named
Nathaniel Richards despite living in the
31st Century Kang's Heritage traces all
the way back to none other than Reed
Richards the smartest man alive and the
leader of the Fantastic Four even though
the cast of Matt shankman's upcoming MCU
Fantastic Four film has yet to be
announced Reed Richards like Kang also
made his MCU debut in Phase 4. he was
portrayed by John Krasinski in a brief
appearance in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness given the
Fantastic Four's impending arrival in
the MCU as well as their importance in
the comic book events of Secret Wars
there's no doubt that Kang and the
Fantastic Four will inevitably cross
paths on the big screen however Kang the
conquerors ties to Reed Richards may be
even more complex than that comic book
fans will know that read Richard's
father also happened to be named
Nathaniel some theorists have speculated
that Reid Richard's father was yet
another variant of Kang the Conqueror
who traveled back in time and created
his own legacy perhaps this will prove
to be an important aspect of Kang's
character in the 2026 film Avengers the
Kang Dynasty King The conqueror's
Fantastic Four ties don't stop with his
lineage the character also draws plenty
of inspiration from one of the biggest
and most popular Fantastic Four
antagonists Dr Doom fan anticipation and
speculation regarding the official MCU
introduction of Dr Doom remains some of
the highest the film franchise has seen
to date the characters closely tied to
the events of Secret Wars in the comics
and his full potential has yet to be
realized on the big screen of course the
introduction of Kang and the promise of
the Fantastic Four means Victor Von Doom
is on a collision course with the MCU
having been defeated by The Fantastic
Four in the comics one variant of Kang
ends up encountering Doctor Doom in the
20th century inspired by the liverian
Conqueror this version of Kang dubs
himself the Scarlet Centurion and forces
The Avengers to face their alternate
selves in a multiversal war he even
takes inspiration from Doom's outfit for
his own for Kang's MCU future it's
possible he'll be inspired by Doom in
any number of ways donning a similar
outfit as Doom is certainly a
possibility as is pitting The Avengers
against each other as the main plot of
Avengers Secret Wars from the look at
John's in Majors Kang in the first
trailer for Ant-Man and the WASP points
Mania it seems his outfit already has Dr
Doom vibes
there are many other Kang the Conqueror
variants whose comic book iterations May
influence the look of Jonathan Majors
portrayal in Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania as well as future
appearances in the MCU one of the
earlier versions of Kang to debut in the
comics appears after Nathaniel Richards
time travels to ancient Egypt there he
becomes a ruler and worshiped figure
amongst the Egyptians under the moniker
ramatut of course Kang the conqueror's
affiliation with ancient Egypt in the
comics perfectly lends the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the opportunity to
have the character come to blows with
Moon Knight and konshu this comic book
premise is an early storyline for the
Fantastic Four who find themselves taken
prisoner by ramitan in the past it's
possible that this storyline could serve
as the basis for the upcoming Fantastic
Four movie which would mean that
Jonathan Majors King could take on the
appearance of an Egyptian pharaoh
nevertheless it's also possible that the
upcoming Fantastic Four film will
revolve around the original team's
encounters with the skrulls who have
also already made their MCU debut
perhaps Kang the conquerors relationship
with ancient Egypt will be explored
through his costume design in future
films such as the Kang Dynasty or even
in the second season of Loki one Major's
appearance in the third Ant-Man movie is
Marvel's super villain Kang the
Conqueror was first announced many fans
were rightfully surprised given the
lighthearted nature of Paul Rudd's MCU
franchise it seemed like an Odd Couple
to pair his smart me Thief with one of
the cruelest and most Sinister
characters that Marvel has to offer
nevertheless the two are set to square
off in the Marvel Cinematic universe's
highly anticipated start to 2023 so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man
the first trailers for Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania have given insight into
what beef there will be between Kang the
Conqueror and Scott Lang after
accidentally ending up in the quantum
realm it appears that canning is hiring
Scott to perform a heist for him which
is certainly in Scott's skill set even
in another dimension fans have
speculated that Kang wants God to steal
back his time chair which is what Kang
uses to time travel other fans
speculation theorizes that the current
owner of Kang's time chair is none other
than Modoc who's also set to appear in
the film some fans believe the time
chair can be spotted in one of the first
trailers to Ant-Man 3. depicting Kang
standing in front of it wearing a very
comic accurate costume though it's
unclear why Kang wants his precious time
travel device back one can assume he
plans to use it for the purpose of doing
you know what he does best conquering
the presence of another significant
Marvel Baddie Modoc may also allude to a
much different path for Kang the
Conqueror than fans are anticipating in
Marvel Comics there's precedence set for
Kang to have a change of heart one
teenage variant of Nathaniel Richards
encounters his future self a bitterly
when Kang time travels to protect his
younger self from a life-altering injury
taking the younger Nathaniel Richards
under his wing Kang attempts to show
himself the legendary ruler he'd become
only for this lecture to frighten him
instead in an attempt to reverse his
Destiny this Nathaniel Richards
assembles a Young Avengers team with
himself as their leader wearing a
stark-esque suit and donning the name
iron lad his teammates include several
characters who have already made their
Marvel Cinematic Universe debuts
including Kate Bishop Elijah Bradley and
Wanda's twin Sons one of Richard's other
assembled teammates is Cassie Lang with
whom he crosses paths during the events
of Quentin Mania despite reports of
Major's role as the next than level
threat in the MCU the plot of Ant-Man 3
could take a sharp turn with Kang having
a moment of redemption with the Young
Avengers potentially being on the
horizon the debut of Jonathan Majors or
another actor as iron lad could come
much sooner than later
another quantumania theory concerns a
certain casting announcement from 2022
to the surprise of many fans the good
place star William Jackson Harper was
confirmed to be appearing in pin Reed's
third Ant-Man film what's even more
interesting is that the actor's role is
apparently top secret though it's more
than likely Harper will join Bill Murray
as some sort of citizen living in the
quantum Place some fans speculate
something much more significant for the
actor notably he's been a front-runner
for many fan castings for the Fantastic
Four particularly in the role of Reed
Richards per the AV club Harper's role
as cheating on the good place certainly
shows he's qualified to capture the
awkwardness and physique of Marvel's
smartest man alive this is especially
true after rumors that John krasinski's
cameos Richards in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness was a one-off
appearance however Harper's potential
casting is Reed Richards could also
prove very relevant to the appearance of
Kang the Conqueror given the comic book
origins of Kang is a descendant of Reed
Richards it would make some sense for
William Jackson Harper to be cast as the
ancestor to Jonathan Majors the only
thing throwing this Theory off is other
rumors surrounding Fantastic Four
casting options including Penn Badgley
and Adam Driver via the direct
while many Marvel Cinematic Universe
fans are Beyond excited for Kang the
Conqueror to make his debut in Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania no one is more
excited than Jonathan Majors himself the
character's role in the film will have a
very big impact on the MCU according to
the film's director Payne Reed in an
interview with Empire predictably it's
this impact on the MCU as a whole that
initially Drew Jonathan Majors to the
role in the first place speaking to
marvel.com on his appearance in the Loki
finale Majors said he was drawn to the
aspect of Kang's character that let him
play many different versions of the same
villain reincarnation baby
on his appearance in Quantum media
Majors had only one thing to say at
Marvel's San Diego Comic-Con panel in
2022 which was there will be conquering
clearly this is only the beginning of
Majors Journey as the character heading
towards Avengers the Kang Dynasty in
[Music]